the modern industry like begins in the
19th century but
its predecessors go back to every known
human civilization I think there's
hardly a I can hardly think of a single
product that we use today that wasn't
used 400 years ago a thousand years ago
even 3,000 years ago so inflection
points really are the late 19th century
when products that were primarily used
by relatively few people made by crap
Smith craft methods suddenly got started
to be turned into into brands and
suddenly started to be sold not just
locally but first regionally then
nationally then globally and that's
really when much of what we think of as
the modern industry really really gets
going then we were looking at stages and
it's its subsequent growth I think the I
think Hollywood was really very
important because Hollywood kind of feel
like raise the stakes of appearance and
it also served as a medium for take
taking beauty ideals round the world and
by the 30s new people in towns almost
everywhere in the world had access to a
cinema they could see representations of
beauty particular hairstyles particular
use of of cosmetics and I think that was
that was enormously are important and if
I'm thinking of a you know more recent
inflection point I'd probably say the
the 1970s when we first begin to see
some really serious criticism about some
aspects of the industry in particular
its impact on people's health there's
there's a giant some cancer
scare about hair dyes and concerns that
the industry was over promising and
begins to be a backlash from then on
which doesn't kill the growth of the
industry not at all but which begins to
reshape it and redefine it
if you go back to the early 19th century
every society and every culture defined
beauty in their own ways people looked
completely different around the world
for example in Japan early 19th century
Japan the epitome of female beauty was
very narrow eyes whitened faces black
teeth elite men I was degrading men in
Japan used cosmetics they also whitened
their face and you can tell the same
story about every other society what
happened over time was this week
recorded a modernization of what it
meant to be beautiful spreading out
throughout the world and beauty came to
be beautiful summers came to see beauty
in very much more sort of uniform or you
could say restrictive terms and this you
know this conception of what it meant to
be beauty was reinforced by television
by Hollywood by the whole ecosystem of
the beauty industry of magazines the
gatekeepers of beauty so consumers if
you take a long-term historical
perspective perspective consumers
conception of what it meant to be
beautiful narrowed and homogenized
dramatically